protests at the world's biggest iPhone
Factory are escalating for days workers
have been leaving the plant in Hanan
Province only to be met with violence by
police in hazmat suits at the center of
the protests China's zero coveted
measures and the poor working conditions
that accompany them
the world's largest iPhone Factory in
jengzhou China hundreds of angry
employers March out of foxconn's
Flagship iPhone plant workers smashed
surveillance cameras pushed over
barriers and marched out against the
wall of police many in hazmat suits
several of the protesting workers live
streamed the protests on social media
Networks the footage showed a brutal
police response the latest round of
protests at the industrial complex which
produces the majority of the world's
iPhones began over a paid dispute among
the newly recruited workers who had been
promised generous bonuses
but workers said the contracts were
changed so they could not get the
bonuses adding that they were
quarantined without food on Thursday
Foxconn released a statement saying the
bonus payments had been delayed due to a
technical error
last month Rising covid-19 cases so the
factory locked down workers were sealed
into their dormitories without medical
care and without food some of the 200
000 workers scaled fences and gates to
break out and go home
Frasier Howie joins us now he's an
analyst focused on the Chinese economy
Frazier welcome back you've studied
China's economy for a long time was this
sort of extreme situation inevitable
well I think it was because ultimately
covert zero is unsustainable
um and this has basically been the
biggest problem for the past a couple of
years really for China that as covert
sort of moves through the planet and
China keeps itself isolated and its
population as would be what we would
call covet naive that at some point
you're going to have these major
disruptions as ultimately China from a
covet standpoint sort of rejoins the
world voluntarily or involuntary
what do you think has to change
fundamentally for conditions for these
workers to improve
sure okay so
okay so in the Foxconn issue the problem
is that you
lifting types of of problems all coming
together you have a population who is
still very concerned about covet you
have an economy that is trying to sort
of keep going
um and you've also got basically
mismanagement of payments and workers
rights so you have a whole host of
influences coming together here to make
the the particular Foxconn issue a real
problem but this is partly because as
well the local officials aren't really
sure what to do because they have
contradictory uh problems as well they
have to provide growth they have to keep
on top of covert they also have to keep
the the the population safe and happy as
well and these are all basically coming
together now and you see the scenes that
we've seen over the past couple of weeks
okay so this is about local officials
also being overwhelmed with the demands
on them but I'm also wondering about
Apple's responsibility here so Apple
claims that it audits working conditions
at suppliers factories like Foxconn how
do you explain these working conditions
then
well ultimately the audits are are from
our standpoint
from this the developed countries from
the European perspective or the American
perspective leader audits are pretty
lightweight there have been lots of
complaints over the years of working
conditions in China and while apples or
Foxconn conditions may be better than
many
um you fundamentally have this problem
and of course you remember in the
particular Fox gun issue at the moment
the the bonuses are not being paid the
wages are not being paid and yeah apple
still takes very high margins on iPhones
so Apple certainly does share part of
this problem but ultimately people are
going to China because of lower working
conditions remember this is a place
which is notorious for poor workers
rights there are ultimately no effective
unions in China to even mediate between
workers and management and so I think
Apple does have a a role to play here
and I noticed that being constructively
quiet about this issue
um of late
no you say that but there's been so much
coverage about this and I was just
wondering whether this will have a
long-term impact perhaps big firms like
apple might switch suppliers to avoid
being associated with accusations of
abusive working conditions what do you
think
um I don't think they'll necessarily
switch suppliers I think it's more a
case of switch venue you've already seen
Apple trying to move into to use
suppliers in other countries and indeed
Chinese factories themselves are
actually moving to other countries like
India and Vietnam to basically take uh
to take advantage of lower wage costs in
China but this is all just part of a
maturation process in China as well the
China is certainly no longer the
cheapest source of Labor in the world so
you're going to see companies moving out
of China the covert situation over the
past few years in China coupled with the
tougher geopolitics is meaning that you
are seeing a sort of decoupling it's not
a complete isolation of China or just a
full disengagement but you are see a an
understanding that there are much
greater China risks
than there were 10 years ago and
companies are responding to that I
changed China Frasier how are you there
thank you very much for your time today
thank you very much